ils repartent discrètement sans un mot
comme toujours pas une parole sur ce
fils qu'ils n'ont pas osé regarder à
l'énoncé du verdict 28 ans de réclusion
pour un jeune homme qui encaisse sans
broncher et qui aura nié jusqu'au bout
je ne parlerai pas de victoire
aujourd'hui c'est la justice est passée
la cour d'assises a suivi mais mes
réquisitions sur la déclaration de
culpabilité
nicolas zepeda été déclaré coupable
d'assassinât pour la justice l'accuse y
avait donc prémédité son geste un point
qui pouvait faire débat même si la
relative brièveté du délibéré cinq
heures seulement laisse penser que
l'intimé conviction des jurés étaient
acquises ils ont toutefois écarté la
perpétuité ce que la défense retient de
cela c'est que le portrait qui avait été
dressé de nicolas zepeda d'un monstre
froid n'a pas été retenu non plus par la
cour d'assises de leur côté les parties
civiles peuvent enfin respirer faute de
corps faute d'aveux les craintes étaient
bien réels de ne pas être entendus la
condamnation est acquise c'est tout ce
qui compte elle ne souhaite pas faire
appel c'est une audience très éprouvante
très émotionnel aussi au delà du travail
professionnel qui a été fait et je pense
que on serait tous satisfaits de
s'arrêter à ce procès là après ça
dépendra exclusivement de la volonté ou
pas de nicolas zepeda contraire à ce bon
ils repartent avec beaucoup de peine
aussi
évidente toujours là la valise et pour
eux toujours aussi gourdon retour avec
toujours autant de questionnements et de
de difficulté à admettre le silence de
nicolas ep
l'université de narumi par la voix d'un
avocat parachuté à besançon dira toute
sa satisfaction de la justice française
appelant de ses voeux la découverte du
corps
nous espérons que madame à crossac y
aura un jour leur prouver auprès de sa
famille
de même qu'il veillera au strict respect
d'une discrétion tout nippone la mère et
la soeur repartiront donc sans un mot
mais après avoir sans doute exorciser un
peu de cinq années de souffrance